good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
day after pub day i
am so sad you're sad and you're also
feeling as you should after a pub day
which is hungover
um yeah yeah
i'm my brain isn't working it's been a
while since
you've given us a hungover episode i
know and they always turned out to be
funny but like you know what it's like
for me like
it's [ __ ] terrible i'm so unwell like
we pushed the show back to this episode
probably will be out a little bit later
than usual
but like and i did all the things you
know i had the bagel and the orange
juice and i chugged water took advil
like
but i'm not better yeah you just need
the day i just need the bed
okay we'll get you to bed but first we
have a job to do and before we
launch into all of that we need to talk
about pub day
pub like pub day pub day
gotta get down on pub day the thing is
is like it felt different than any other
day and i don't know if it was just like
for me but like the world but not for me
the world had different energy yesterday
like i don't know if the world was
excited about my book but it really felt
like they were
yeah so many people were excited and i
think your world was so excited
that's really all that and the world
yeah and yes like the whole globe yeah i
agree so tell us a little bit about your
day some of the highs i don't think
there was even one low
no there literally was not um but
i don't want to give away too much about
my day because i did vlog the whole day
for patreon
but it was just a fabulous day like it
was work but it was
so fun i was so tired because i was
literally up
um i don't want to spoil it but on the
vlog i do say what time i was awake yeah
and it was just very exciting very
overwhelming very emotional you know
yes i saw in your instagram story i was
like crying all
day and i think that's what's supposed
to happen on pub day
yeah i can imagine it's a very emotional
thing to put out a book this is like you
know your life
this is very personal to you yes and to
have other people consume it and then
like share their personal experiences
it's all very emotional so
that's what it is like people like my
mess my instagram it was like my
birthday
on steroids like so many messages so
many tags and like you know that that is
like what means the most to me
and it was just so exciting like every
time it's like 99 plus people mentioned
you and your story and messages
and the messages of people sharing
but the people in my life sharing like
how they remember things
and then like people who are strangers
just like sharing
their stories with grief and it was just
like it was overwhelming to like in
take all that emotion yeah it's
very emotional emotional information
yeah but
i mean you're doing something right i'm
just thrilled you know
it's just charting all over the place
everyone's loving the book and it's
you know it's just now you get to enjoy
the fruits of your labor like yes
you this is like the payoff of a secret
project all year you've had to hold this
thing in now
and now it's like bursting at the seams
it's like vomiting out of you
now i understand you know i understand
no it's such a great day for me
yes and today i know you're hungover
today but today you're doing one of the
most important interviews
of your life oh my god i really have to
get better i i
because i'm taking it really seriously
and at present moment
it's not gonna work no but you have
hours to get better we are recording the
redheads with claudia
and all the girls and we're really
excited it's our first author spotlight
and we have inside the author's studio
we each have come up with our own like
questions
personal questions for you and we're
also taking so many questions from our
listeners
so email your questions about the book
to the redheads book club at gmail.com
and any surplus of questions that we
don't get to we're going to do a patreon
q a you and i
oh funny so we can even go even deeper
love that for us
love that for us you know i haven't
gotten just like a standard manicure
not gel in years and
i had like no time on monday and for gma
i didn't want to have bed now so i just
got
like a polish monday it is wednesday
morning one two three
four five six seven of them are chipped
yeah i mean i'm i never get gel
manicures because i just they're too
harmful to my nails my nails are so
delicate and brittle and like they grow
really nicely but then they
break like on below
my nail line and then it's just a whole
thing um i got this manicure on friday
it still looks decent but then i also
um like cracked my nail with a potato
peeler like i literally
oh no no oh no no
no no no no no don't finish the story
like i
know oh yeah and so this little
[Laughter]
[Music]
this little stop of mine i'm gonna let
it
shine let it shine let it shine
let it shine yes
so good yes um also i'd be rdh if i
didn't wish
a happy birthday to dana because she
listens to the show and
her birthday's so important to her
redhead queen singer songwriter
tnn queen i think we should sing mdb
for her in honor of her birthday oh wow
okay how does it kick off
down the toilet out the sewer into all
that gross manure steal the water
spinning round then i slam the lid back
down my tutti brown
my duty brown my duty
into my mouth goes the food now
into my stomach down it goes now
the bridge is tough yeah my judy brown
my duty brown my judy brown
my duty
such a good song happy birthday dana
um so yeah it's just an exciting time to
be someone who enjoys to read you know
it's so true you know and who enjoys
listening to podcasts audiobooks
available now at girlfriendjob.com
did you see that a lot of people are
really enjoying your audiobook so much
so that it's number one in the audiobook
store
yes but like there is a thread in toast
after dark about how
if you fast forward it to 1.2
then you're talking the same speed that
you talk on the toes yes a lot of people
are feeling very shooketh by the speed
at which i'm reading on the audiobook
and that's because i was not in control
like
they told me to slow down every five
minutes and honestly i did listen to a
snippet of it this morning and like it
does sound weird
because it's just not how i talk yes so
but if you put it on 1.2 speed people
say it's
what you're used to it'll be more a
little bit something like this
perfect so i think without further ado
let's dive into what we've got to do
because we have a lot to do today
and you have a lot of napping to make up
for i have
so many naps to take like you have no
idea yeah so without further ado it's
time for the fast time stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
but i did think i was gonna hit up some
more bookstores today i mean it's very
ambitious of me given the fact that like
i'm
literally broken on the inside but i did
want to hit up some more bookstores
because you know yesterday i went on a
journey
to a couple different barnes and nobles
and i have to say like
if ever one day like we want to quit i
am getting a job at barnes and noble
like
it was literally the most [ __ ]
peaceful place so quiet like
so much silence and all they sell is
like board games and books and
chocolate and coffee your favorite
things you know it was so
peaceful like i was literally jealous of
the manager i'm like i want your job
like you get a part-time job no
literally that sounds heavenly
if borders were still open because those
were like more like iconic like
clubhouse like vibes i would have worked
at a board legacy box
legacy box is an effortless way to
digitally preserve your home movies and
photos
so that you never have to wonder where
they are or whether they're safe
now i get messages all the time like
what was the legacy box code or what was
that company
please pay attention please okay cause
here's here's what you need to know
legacy box is literally the most amazing
concept for a company i can't believe i
didn't come up with it myself
digitally preserving old vcr i'm sure
you have like boxes we used to have like
boxes of like digital
not digital photos and
records and tapes and and they just take
care of it and
they digitize it so that you can access
all of those old memories
thank you for speaking when i couldn't
um you have all the footage organized
and preserved quickly and easily you use
their kit to safely send the moments you
want preserved
their experienced team will create a
digital collection by hand and then
it'll all come back to you stored on the
cloud a thumb drive or dvd
along with the original media you sent
with their tracking system you can
follow every step of the process so you
always know your where you
always know your original items are
secure legacy box has helped the more
than one million families restore
protect restore and protect
irreplaceable moments from the past
if you want to check it out we've got a
quite quite the offer for you guys
go to legacybox.com toast to take
advantage of this limited time offer and
get 50
off this exclusive offer won't last long
so order their kit now and send it in
whenever you're ready
go to legacy box dot com slash toast and
save
50 percent while supplies last so when
you visit legacybox.com
today you will save fifty percent off
just gotta go to legacybox.com toast
love it sign on preserve your memories
okay sorry like that was
really hard for me yeah okay first the
letters were like moving the tea
is so hot today okay girl with no job
claudia ashrae spills on her plastic
surgeries including chin
implant botox and lip fillers in her new
book okay so yes it's true
it's true i'm becoming somewhat of like
a joan rivers
janice taking dickinson i was going to
say giannisian
um yeah like that's my legacy and i'm
so so so proud yeah girl with no jobs
claudia ashrae grew her instagram
following
by posting relatable content which is
why she decided to be open with her
audience about her plastic surgery
the 26 year old revealed all the details
about her change
aging me i think that your age is
germane to the story because it's like
it is you know at your age sometimes
determines
how much plastic surgery like it's
important to know how old the person
wants yeah
about her chin surgery botox and lip
fillers in her new book
claudia released her memoir on tuesday
where she explains why she decided to
get the procedures done
some because she wanted them some
because she wanted to seem quote cool
wow that's pathetic no but like that is
what i literally
wrote it and you said that it's pathetic
the social media influencer admitted
she'd always hated her double chin and
while she could hide other aspects of
her body
she was unhappy with aspects of her body
that she wasn't happy with
she couldn't do the same with her chin
the decision to get my chin procedure
took me all of two seconds to make she
writes so yeah girls no job is being
super honest in her new
book about all of the cosmetic
procedures that she has had done
and i guess there are a lot i mean
knowing you it's like i wouldn't think
of you
as a plastic surgery queen reading this
article i'm like yeah i guess that's
more than your average 26 year old you
know it's like i definitely like have
made the foray into plastic surgery but
like
i don't know i don't think of myself as
like a plastic queen but like maybe i am
and i'm okay with that
but i also plastic surgery i think now
it encompasses like a lot of different
things but doesn't it require you to
have something
plastic in your body well no and like
you know like
like a silicone breast i'm sure but i
think it's also just like cosmetic
surgery when like at the end of the day
lip fillers and botox don't count they
dissolve like it's not like i'm changing
my face so like i think
that these days botox is just considered
plastic surgery even though
because it's done by a plastic surgeon
yeah yeah yeah
i just love like this article like
referring to me just as like a
regular celebrity and i
i so appreciate whoever wrote this
article like
i don't know i didn't pitch this article
like literally it just came up on its
own accord
and that has happened to me articles you
know sneaking up on me and they're never
as positive as this
and i think that this is so exciting and
what's the
author's name rachel ellenboggen rachel
ellenboggen you sound like a [ __ ]
queen
and i absolutely adore you thank you for
this opportunity
and i respect the sun i don't even know
i know it's a british publication and
they sometimes are guilty
of perpetuating kelly's mindless news
because i see this this is claudia's
mindless news and i feel like that's
all we're looking for wait claudi's
mindless
news like this no i feel wait
i feel like i've just made a connection
well you made it actually
this is what it feels like to be kelly
clarkson
i can't [ __ ] talk today this must be
what it feels like
to be kelly ripa like this is what she
does she's just like oh everyone's just
reading about my mindlessness
yeah except that if we were to read an
article about kelly's plastic surgery
that would be
not mindless at all that'd be super
interesting yeah for sure
the sun get on it rachel right yeah fine
get the t
i got to get in communication with rage
because i need to write more flattering
articles about me
rach if you hear this like please keep
going don't stop no
email me i will give you like my address
you can send the
paparazzi like just hit me up girlfriend
hit me yeah you'll bring her with you
next time you go to dr gazi
yes dr gizi on me in exchange for you
know one good mindless article a week
i think that's fair i think that's more
than kelly gives
uh yeah i know kelly doesn't get much
that's what i've heard you know through
my contacts
okay next story another celeb who's
spilling the team
colton underwood details every step of
his split with cassie randolph for the
first time
okay well jump to the page where he's
talking about his restraining order
yeah no i didn't see that part in this
roundup from e news basically what he
says
is where did he say this he um
he penned a new final chapter to his
book and i'm not sure where he posted it
or
like if you buy the book now yeah i'm
not sure where
he posted his new chapter but he just
wrote like the final chapter
which is literally what we said last
week like you wrote the book before the
final chapter
right happened so then he like went back
and wrote a chapter it's kind of shady
of him to like do that on my pub day
like yeah no he's just trying to ride
your coattails no i think it's really
uncool
i know but he was inspired by what we
said on the show what can you blame him
that's true um okay so he wrote a book
so he wrote another chapter explaining
what happened between the two of them
and he made it seem like very you know
falling out of love and he doesn't
really address the restraining order but
he did say like he
he didn't accept that they were breaking
up you know he didn't want it to be true
he didn't want to put on an instagram
statement because he just didn't want
that to be the truth like he loved cass
but he felt like she felt like he didn't
understand her like being from her like
small
town and just wanting to be like a chill
girl
small town she's from like the she's
from the beach town
i don't know if i would say huntington
beach is like a small town i'm pretty
sure he called her yeah he called her a
small town
girl who liked the slow pace and quiet
of her beachside hometown
okay nicholas sparks over here like
first of all
when you i just think it's important to
know like while yes okay wherever cassie
may be from
might technically be a town that is
small if you're gonna refer to someone a
small town like they better be wearing
cowboy boots like
yeah it's just it's it's not a good
descriptor you know
from one author to another he says cass
felt like there was pressure on her to
commit one way or the other because of
our relationship
because of the way our relationship
unfolded so publicly on tv
i tried to give her space she didn't
feel like i saw all the different sides
of her
especially the small town girl who liked
the slow pace and quiet of her beachside
hometown
girl sometimes sometimes she would say
outright i feel like you don't
understand me
um he said that the issue was pushed to
the back burner when he got
covered and like her family took care of
him
torture it's like you want to break up
with someone now he's got covered in
your basement yeah
but then he recovered and all the issues
came back to the forefront he said
it was when cass and i finally tried to
grab back a bit of normalcy that i
realized the virus was only part of a
much larger problem
after more than a month of being cooped
up in her family's home both of us were
feeling overwhelmed and smothered
and eager to return to our respective
apartments where we could enjoy our own
space
before we left though she took me aside
and told me she was struggling with
everything on her
relationship and didn't know what to do
my head spun like one of those
characters in a cartoon
what she was struggling with everything
um
he he said once the shock wore off he
realized that the misfires and miscues
between them were actually more like one
of those proverbial death by a thousand
paper cuts
no he's just yeah inspiration from
claudia ashrae taylor swift nicholas
sparks did he just [ __ ] quote taylor
swift
yeah though that is like a common phrase
that she made
death by a thousand guests so what he's
saying it's a lot of little things and i
just
um i need to hear from i need to
cassie's chapter i'm really
yeah i'm so uninterested in hearing
about the relationship
from the perspective of the nut job who
got a restraining order like
i want to hear from [ __ ] cassie and i
know she don't want to talk about it
because she's like
can i be my own person like colton is
just like
milking this breakup when he really
should publicly stop talking about it
because it reminds
us of how [ __ ] crazy yeah like we
were starting to forget there's been
like two crazy seasons of the bachelor
like we've moved on
not top of mind i think he could just
like go and you know
do his thing but he keeps bringing it
back to the surface and i'm sure if they
ever had a chance of getting back
together every time she sees her name
associated with him she's like
no yeah get me out of here yeah so
i don't know i hope somebody's counting
how many times i'll be on today
yeah they're contagious so i don't wanna
they are contagious they're so
contagious
i probably mentioned this on the show
already because you know i am you know a
girl with four stories
and i share them all all the time but
when i always took the sats remember
there was the reading section the
writing section math section
the reading section in one of the
reading sections i got a passage
all about yawning about how some some
scientists believe yawning to be a
social construct
but there's a lot of evidence that
yawning is contagious
and sometimes even reading the word yawn
can make a person yawn and so i'm trying
to take the sats
and i'm reading this lengthy ass
[ __ ] chapter about yawns
and i'm just can't stop yawning and i do
feel as though
it was unfair let me know did anyone
else get that passage because like
someone must have taken the same
test as me for sure i'm sure thousands
yeah anybody get that let me know
hit me up sweet in the dms even though
my dm's are just like so popping i don't
know if i'll see it because like
everyone is like obsessed with my book
um speaking
of your book next story girl with no
job's friend paris hilton reveals she
started the ivs pro ivf process with her
boyfriend she says it was tough
but worth it paris hilton is opening up
about her plans to start a family
the dj and harris revealed on tuesday's
episode of the trend reporter with mara
podcast
that she started ivf with her boyfriend
carter vroom
praising the 39 year old businessman for
being quote so supportive throughout the
process
oh so she has a businessman bow i don't
know if i knew that uh i didn't know
that
of course but i didn't know he was in
the business man category yeah no
um he is and i think that this is so
great
because in her documentary she was
talking about it like i don't know if
it's yeah so i think that this is so
awesome
i hope you know she gets everything that
she's looking for quarantine is like
making people you know baby crazy
yeah babe crazy
i'm having a lot of problems my nose is
there anything we can get you
honestly can i get a tissue okay because
i'm like leaky
i'm nene leakes with my like my nose is
like you do sound a little stuffed up
i always get stuffy like when i ha i'm
hungover like
like a cold you know yeah yeah and
you gotta like get out all the toxins
toxins
thank you so very much you are a doll
um and i'm just gonna yeah just if you
want
my mic so i can not torture everyone
meanwhile
slash a book get a copy of this
wonderful book treat yourself
it'll probably arrive in time for the
weekend and you can just have a
wonderful weekend
reading the beautiful words of claudia
ashrae
okay that was a life-changing nose blow
wow
i'm so glad oh my god i sound better
right
yeah more lively yeah for sure more like
live life
okay our next story chris please oh what
i'm i
i'm waiting for a story like oh that's
the fifth and final i'm
so excited for the fifth and final okay
but our fourth and second to last is
kristen stewart's first photo as
princess diana is here
the resemblance is double take worthy so
as we reported a few months ago kristen
stewart is playing princess diana in a
movie about princess diana like one of
many
you know when it rains it pours snow
white in the huntsman mirror mirror like
no no
she literally lady dai
is like the british jonbenet like
people just keep making movies yeah but
also i don't i've never really watched a
movie about
lady die like and now it feels like
there's four in one year especially with
the crown starting to cover it
yes you know right no it feels
overwhelming now because of the crowd
yeah it's like just every when it rains
it pours we always say this but
every few years like someone just makes
a lady diana something
i don't know i feel like this is the
first one like there hasn't been one
that's like
oscar contender right right you know
this definitely anything with kristen
stewart like gets nominated
yes to celebrate the start of principal
photography on pablo lorraine's film
spencer neon has released the first look
of their star in full costume
that's actually like a really great way
to drum up some excitement for your
movie
because now i'm excited again and it's
like now i realize okay they started
filming like
they're giving us good intermittent
bursts of excitement
i love love love intermittent bursts of
excitement and now they're gonna film
the movie and then in a few months we'll
get a trailer yeah a few months the
movie will be here and i feel like it's
just a good way it's a good strategy no
and i think that anyone who's not using
intermittent bursts of
excitement excitement is doing it all
wrong no it's so
important so important to have
intermittent bursts of
excitement steward bears a strong
resemblance to the late royal in a red
coat blonde locks and a black hat with
delicate netting over her face as she
looks off to the side and yes a
very diana spencer sort of look and a
very dennis spencer jawline like
caroline you know she looks iconic she
also does
look like emma as princess diana
and i'm just i'm really here for it and
i i can't remember what our take was
when she was
announced as the cast i'm sure it was
negative
and i know us yeah i feel like i
remember us recording and i feel like
you were negative
and i was on the fence that sounds uh on
track but i do remember us
defending her as an actress because we
believe you know twilight
she's one of those so compelling she's
one of the greatest actresses of our
generation don't at me
no you're right and if you watch
twilight and like take it seriously like
you will see stellar
acting and like the most passionate
beautiful love story of a generation
yeah i agree so spencer is a dive the
movie's called spencer it's a dive
inside an emotional imagining of who
diana
the movie's called spencer because diana
was already taken by another diana
documentary
yeah um it's an imagining of who diana
was at a pivotal turning point in her
life it is a physical
assertion of the sum of her parts which
starts with her given name
spencer you know i hate that phrase
this sum of one's parts like it's
honestly disgusting
like no but keep it to yourself the
movie chronicles
the um the sum of her parts the course
of the weekend in december 1991 when
princess diana joins the royal family
for christmas at sandringham
and decides to leave her fractured
marriage to prince charles so i believe
that we
saw that scene it's just it's just of
one weekend which really irks me that's
like that movie
jack jackie my husband
yeah when you think you're getting a
whole duck like and you get a weekend
yeah you think you're getting jackie o's
life story instead
yes the week after her husband died
literally never been more disappointed
in my life when i realized
that that movie is not a fabulous life
in the d
and fabulous picture into the life of
jackie o
but it was like the worst day for jackie
ever yeah no i i
talked weird i really don't like that
idea for movies i feel like there was
even a recent like marilyn monroe movie
my week with marilyn where it's like
what about life what about what about
yeah know the lifetime of marilyn
yeah so this is kind of a bummer and i i
think that christmas at sandringham when
she decides she's going to leave charles
is when she we saw in the crown when
prince prince ed phillip prince philip
came and gave her talking to
yeah gotta get to sandringham
like need a castle on a hill yeah shoot
four
so i'm like i'll obviously be watching
this movie but i do
want a life story of princess anna from
the beginning to the end
you know yeah and do you follow kitty
spencer on instagram of course i do
she follows she's a literal queen she's
a literal
queen she's is what her lady
is niece yeah she's pregnant harry and
william lady diana was an auntie
harry and william's cousins um well
she's just so gorgeous and like she i
feel like has the best of both worlds
because
she's really like a a private citizen
like she's not a
working royal yeah but she is a lady
right
yeah and she's just so sick in england
she's connected to like
iconic princess anna she's like the most
like uh it girl in fashion yeah no she's
everything on the story she's a great
instagram follower
actually i don't even know if she's a
lady i don't know if she has a title
i don't know i feel like these days you
could just slap one on yeah who's lucky
you just buy one
yeah i mean scott district did it
yes okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story that you've been dying to
talk about i'm so thrilled is it the
fifth and final story that i've been
dying to talk about that's brought to
you by manscape
yes it is okay manscape is everything of
the sort
it literally arrived at my house and ben
has not stopped using it
have you ever felt like taking a bite
out of your partner's morning toast but
there's like
hair everywhere well roses are red
violets are blue get manscaped as a gift
for v-day and he'll say
i love you our friends at mask manscaped
are the global leaders in men's below
the ways screaming and they are here to
give you the perfect gift
for the men in your life two million men
are already trusting manscaped products
to groom make sure your man is one of
them
so um first of all this is like the best
name
for uh men's screaming men's grooming
has the uh the razor it's electric it's
first of all so cute
it's so cute i got a box from manscaped
and like
zach was looking at me like i hung the
moon he was so excited he had seen that
razor but hadn't gotten it yet
and i got it for him and he loves it
yeah it's
creating problems for me because like
now i have to clean up all the hair that
ben leaves but
it does look it's there's a visible
difference um on his face
from like the crappy drugstore one he
had before in this one
and also like all of the manscape
products like are just aesthetically
pleasing to look at so
yeah your man is using all manscape
products and keep even if they don't put
them away in the bathroom like if it's
just on the counter it's really not
as annoying as it could be when it's
like a lot of different products from
different brands and it just looks a
mess so if you can't think of what to
get your partner this year get the gift
that's for you and for him
the best way to start is with the
manscaped perfect package 3.0
full of the best products to keep him
looking smelling and feeling nice for
both of you
the perfect package 3.0 is led by their
revolutionary third
generation lawn mower trimmer which has
advanced that's the one
yeah which has advanced skin safe
technology and features a cutting-edge
ceramic blade
to reduce grooming accidents um if you
want to get 20
off plus free shipping use the code
morning at manscaped.com their
formulations are vegan cruelty free die
free self free free and paraben free
so you know that his manhood is in good
hands hands their products smell good
uh they have deodorant they have a toner
and they're just like manly you know so
like people will use them
uh again that's 20 off if you use the
code morning at
manscaped.com you'll also get free
shipping and the 20 off like i said at
manscape.com
code morning happy valentine's day love
it that
box is what i got for a sack and like it
is everything of the sort and
everything is so glad agree okay fifth
and final
story former real housewives of new york
star barbara
k as we know her enters the nyc mayoral
race
this is hysterical former roni star
barbara kay has officially announced
she's running for mayor of new york city
adding to an already crowded field of
democratic candidates
the bronx-born cabavette is what the
case stands for
made it i didn't know that no me either
made it official on her instagram
wednesday
saying her beloved big apple is quote in
a state of crisis under mayor
de blasio's watch she said quote i may
not be a politician but i'm a bronx born
new yorker
who isn't fearful of the hard work and
tough decisions that lay ahead
it will take a builder to rebuild nyc
and i'm the woman to do it that's a
great line because she works
she's barb the builder yeah in september
she
um had floated her dreams of gracie
mansion telling page six she was ready
to rebuild the city
by the way can i just say like you're
not a new yorker
if you don't at one point in your life
like think about running for mayor like
it's come across the minds of everyone
ben literally
not a week ago i was like i should run
for mayor i'm like yeah okay good luck
yeah she said number one is rebuild a
safer and more inclusive new york city
she said this in september so i feel
like the city is not a safe place so if
it's not safe people don't want to come
to new york city
people don't want to stay in new york
city she's making stating facts
yeah so she's making waves with her
announcement i just feel like
and i'm going to give you know everyone
a chance i just feel like if you can't
make it on real housewives of new york
oh what chance
do you stand no you're right and of the
mayoral race which is
there's so many people throwing their
hats in the ring if
you are going to run for mayor
where was i taking this sentence i don't
recall but i was gonna say
is that if you've made it on real
housewives like successfully
you actually are incredibly qualified to
run for mayor 100
yeah because you've been through a lot
you've been through a lot but also like
not even about the task of
of being mayor but like you know the
politics
yeah of running oh yeah i don't know
like in new york it's just like someone
just becomes mayor it's like not even an
election it's just like they tell you
it's crazy like
this is de blasio no i don't know anyone
who actually voted for him like
it's crazy not one person camera light
wait also i saw the craziest
[ __ ] moment from a press conference
with bill de blasio did you see no what
did he do
so it turns out like he's been keeping
his gym open and using it
but like it's not allowing any other
gyms to be open so a reporter was like
how come your gym can be open but like
no one else's can
and his gym like the gym that he goes to
okay
it's allowed to be open because he goes
there and
his response was so crazy he was like he
got like angry and defensive at the
reporter and he was like
i have to work out so that i can stay
healthy and do my job and run this city
i'm like
what like that is just not even a real
[ __ ] answer like it was so crazy
like when was this i don't know i saw it
on tick tock it must have been in the
last couple weeks
no but but gyms are open oh that's true
you know so maybe it was like
a while ago pre the opening of gyms i
can't believe that didn't go more viral
it was such a
lunatic thing to say like it's clear
that he's thrown in the towel
yeah and you know what literally
literally literally
at the gym and there's lots of exciting
things happening in the new york city
mayoral race
barber k obviously being one of them but
i'm very much looking forward to a new
frontier
yeah i just feel like we're talking
about real housewives of new york who
should be running for mayor like we need
to be talking to bethany frankel
i just feel like yes she like
infrastructure wise like if you can do
the job of
organizing a charity organization like
she has like
you have some chops i'm sure people
tell bethany all the time that she
should run for them i wonder what her
argument
is for not because i'm sure that she has
one
i mean she'll be running i think that
like she has a happy life and a
successful business and like who the
[ __ ] wants the job
even if you do a good job as mayor it's
like it's in our blood as new yorkers to
be like
the [ __ ] mayor like even like i
remember when i was in high school and
bloomberg was the mayor who was like a
beloved like really he did a good job
the cab drivers
everyone was like [ __ ] bloomberg like
yeah you did a good job like you're
always talking [ __ ] about the mayor
bill de blasio is a different
animal because he's actually like
destroying the city
and people are talking [ __ ] about him
like because he deserves it yeah but
um it's not just like angry new york
energy it's not no it's not it's not
because there is that and you have to
accept that because even good mayors get
that angry energy but
this doesn't you know they do they do a
good job they don't know the candle
so was mike bloomberg the mayor before
de blasio
oh my god it's been mayor for a long
time yeah because it's like two terms
and the mayoral terms are pretty long i
can't wait
like for new symbols yeah i agree
there's some handsome men
the race is going to start revving up
and barbara kay yes honestly i'm good i
want to enter her platform
yeah no i i definitely when i first saw
this i was just like
if you can't make it as a housewife you
can't make it as a mayor but really and
this is like silly yeah but you know
what i'm i have my eyes and my ears open
you know yes no i'm getting very
involved in the mayoral race
yeah yeah very exciting very exciting
and we're wishing you the best of luck
bob we are we are
and it's wednesday dear toasters
dear toasters
do you want me to read them i offered
that i did offer but i'm feeling better
if the letters start to move off the
page i will fork this over
dear toasters is our advice segment
where we give honestly what i think to
be
stellar advice i think our advice gets
better and better
every week i would agree and you can
write it to us at deartoasters gmail.com
we will always keep it anonymous
good morning jackie claudia and of
course theo good morning
thank you for putting some respect on
his name let me preface by saying you
are the perfect people to ask for advice
seeing as that claudia is pro-snoop and
jackie is anti-snoop
great we love a balanced debate i was
convinced that over the holidays my
boyfriend of three and a half years was
going to propose
i fixed my covered roots painted my
nails the whole nine yards
christmas and new years came and went
and nothing so you can imagine i had a
major case of rdh
i was so upset literal rdh no
heartbroken
i was so upset and wanted to know what
was going on that i snooped through his
texts
i saw that he asked my best friend for
advice on a ring and sent my uncle who
is a jeweler a check
great so now here's my dilemma i'm going
insane knowing that he bought the ring
but it's not but
uh not knowing when it's gonna happen as
two ladies who have been through this
process did you know it was coming if so
how did you remain calm
please give me advice on how to stay
until i get that ring sincerely a snoopy
unengaged toaster
okay i thought this was going south me
too you're in a very good spot
yeah you're looking for problems
girlfriend like just let it happen
you're not looking for problems
i just think that like there are so few
times especially like in
the modern world where everyone knows
everything about everyone there are so
few times where you can experience
genuine surprise and you're so smart
like now that you know
that it's coming and he has the ring you
don't have to be like worry if if this
is your partner like you don't have to
ask yourself those big questions
so i think don't worry about the
manicure and the roots because like
once you you can worry about the roots
no but like once you're married or
planning the wedding like i never look
back on my engagement photos i'm like
thank god i got a manicure like
it those things really don't matter and
i think the the
being surprised is the best possible way
to be
proposed to agree and i think you should
sit back and let him do it in his own
way on his own time
and really not snoop in like for
yourself too so that you can experience
it i feel like
i knew like a the season which zach was
gonna
propose to me but on the night that it
happened i had absolutely no idea i just
thought we were going to dinner because
he had like sent me an
invite for this event and we had had a
pretty busy day yeah i'm into my mind
claudia writes about it in her book
actually so my mind was just
elsewhere um but even if it hadn't been
like i remember we had such a busy day
but i was like but damn i have to go to
dinner tonight like i told my boyfriend
like i would have canceled like that's
what that is what's so funny like
anybody anybody else would have canceled
you could have gotten me out of bed that
day like yeah no but i was like i made a
commitment like i have to go to this
dinner
and you're a stand-up gal because of it
yeah and so i
being genuinely surprised like it's the
best feeling so
i would say let go and let him have his
moment
i have literally not one thing to add
because you said it all hey claud and
jack
hi your darn i have a bit of a situation
that i could use some advice on
my husband joe and i have been spending
a lot of time with my single best friend
of 15 years in the queue
i don't like where this is me neither my
best friend let's call her jess
we grew up together went to school
together and has been around my whole
relationship with jo even in our wedding
party she's always been in and out of
relationships
and she still hasn't found the one two
weeks later
after we had spent new year's eve
together drinking and having a fire pit
at our house oh
that sounds fun my friend told me that
she didn't feel comfortable spending
time around us anymore when i pressed
her on why she told me that she had
serious feelings for joe and she finds
it confusing to spend time with us
i asked her if something happened
between them and she said no to make
matters worse when i told my husband
about the confession he told me he had
always found jess attractive
and that she was really more of a his
traditional type before he met me
why the [ __ ] would you say that joe i
smell that smells like divorce
oh that is not funny like stop okay
so he said it was more of a traditional
type i am now super insecure about my
relationship and devastated that my best
friend dumped this on me
we haven't spoken in two weeks and
things are super awkward at home with my
husband
how do we move past this oh my god you
okay
you can move past this it's just gonna
take a lot of really mental
and emotional maturity from you like
that
obviously your husband loves you he has
chosen you he had chosen
poor choice of words a few weeks ago and
now you're left like with this
big pile of [ __ ] to clean up but i think
you can clean it up
and you guys can move on from this and i
don't think that anything went on i
don't think that they changed
either obviously they both wouldn't have
been so upfront with you right and
he wouldn't have said those things if he
was hiding right it's just like he's
made an
awkward situation even worse your
friendship with this girl is gonna have
to take a backseat for a while she won't
be hanging out with you guys until
i think she's in a committed
relationship of her own unfortunately
that unless you want to choose your
friendship with her over your husband
but it sounds like everything otherwise
is okay
like why the [ __ ] would this girl say
that like no and why would he
say that too but but only someone who's
innocent
would say such damning words i agree
and you know what i feel like if you
can't move past this on
your own which would be very
understandable i think maybe it's time
to bring in a counselor a mat
like a a counselor you know like a for
real like
try some therapy and like work through
these things so that like
the counselor is probing him and he can
get out
words that will make you feel more
certain in your situation
yeah these are this is just like a like
a moment in time in your marriage where
you're just gonna have to put in the
work do the work
and it's it's not it's not the end of
the world
really but it's just uncomfortable yeah
but it's very
it's not the end of the world no it's
not the end of the world but i feel for
you
all right our third and final dear
claudia and jackie i recently broke up
with my boyfriend of almost five years
before we broke up i was asked to be a
bridesmaid in one of his best friend's
weddings
i had only met the fiance three to four
times so i found it really strange to
begin with
when we broke up i told her i didn't
feel comfortable being in the wedding
anymore because i knew
she just had asked me because my
boyfriend at the time was a groomsman
she completely understood and was so
sweet fast forward two months later she
is now questioning why i'm not wanting
to attend the wedding as a guest or
attend the rehearsal dinner
i've explained to her why i don't feel
comfortable since i have not seen her
spoken to my ex since we broke up
i've tried to tell her that her wedding
is about her special day and not about
me
and i don't want the attention taken off
of her please give me some advice on how
i should handle this
side note i have attended two wedding
showers for her and i was putting in an
effort to show her i did care
please help xoxo why is this girl
getting so butt hurt uh
you said you can't attend a wedding no
no and it's literally like
you sound lovely but you're not
important to the wedding like yeah
you're
it's giving you a little bit of like
wedding ring or situation like vibes
where it's like she doesn't have
many close friends oh well in that case
then that's but i just feel like you're
being so emotionally mature like
you broke up with this man and you don't
want to be around him and i think that
you can maybe
make that clear to her but i agree it's
weird on her that she's so invested in
the attendance of a guest who was at one
point just a plus one
right and also it's i don't know she
said it very like casually but
making a girl a groomsman i'm sorry
making a girl a bridesmaid
what yeah yeah okay are you ready for
this
are you ready yeah making a girl
agreement [ __ ]
oh my god are you ready no making a girl
a bridesmaid
simply because her boyfriend is a
groomsman is
so losery on behalf of the bride it's
just so unnecessary
you know it's desperate like yeah
pathetic
no it's just like maybe she just doesn't
have that many close friends and maybe
like these two people
met each other a few times and just hit
it off like you you know when you're
gonna be friends with somebody i agree
no i i don't i
think they take it back not desperate
but like it's bizarre yeah it's bizarre
but you know sometimes like
you know two people hit it off and if
their boyfriends are super close
then they would have been in each
other's lives forever and it's like oh
and we get along great
i'll make you a bridesmaid but the fact
that you don't want to participate like
she shouldn't be taking so personally
i i have another theory for why this
bride really needs this girl at the
wedding
because like it's like she needs her to
be in this place you know because like
she's a spy
and like literally there's like a target
and they like need her at
this particular wedding so they can pick
her up and question her
yeah or maybe she's trying to get you
there because like your
ex-boyfriend wants to propose to you and
oh wait that's actually a good good call
and so she wants to get like all dressed
up for the wedding
they can do one of those things i see on
instagram when they pretend to throw the
bouquet then they actually just give it
to the bridesmaid and she turns around
and her boyfriend's on the floor i've
never
seen that but i thought that as a
society we're all like
against getting proposing to someone at
someone else's wedding well so every
time
it happens in america um the video goes
viral because it's only happened like
five or six times
only five or six people would be so
shameful so stupid
and literally no but the bride is like
involved and it's like the end of her
wedding when you throw the bouquet so
it's meant to like signify like
i understand but i'm not even saying
like i'm saying
i wouldn't be mad as the bride meaning
i'm mad
as though the fiance i'm like you're
[ __ ] proposing to me
pardon me
i'm like you [ __ ] cheap [ __ ] buy me
real flowers
like used photos yeah i'm like this is
someone else
[Laughter]
or like i don't i'd rather have no
flowers than
someone else's flowers it's such like
flowers that were bought with a
different intention i don't know what
the right word is in english but like
they get i sound like hilaria baldwin
[Laughter]
but it's like such a hazard thing to do
yeah i think cause
it's like yeah that's what i'm thinking
yeah it's like get your
own like particular also translates to
pig
perfect yeah it's like a thing to do
oh my god that is funny so that was your
toasters
again deartoasters gmail.com it's so
simple no one is ever like hey what's
the email for dear toasters because it
literally
actually you think i've actually seen
posts oh yeah
like what's the email for yourself
explanatory also someone like called you
out so hard
about it yeah because you made fun of me
for taking redhead questions from an
email address
i know and literally in your next breath
you were like email us
today toasters gmail.com stop
i know i take it back thank you
my book is available at girlsnowjob.com
book ebook audiobook it is on every
platform you don't have to you have to
say
hey can i get it you can like i'm
telling you you can get it i also went
to a bunch of
barnes and nobles yesterday in the city
and signed some copies
i do believe that a lot of them are gone
but if you want to check out and you'll
also be doing it like throughout the
week
yes i'm gonna go to tribeca and the
bronx and yonkers
and i think over the weekend i'm gonna
take a trip to like long island i love
that for you maybe i'll come i could go
for a good car ride and like a good
bagel like
and good music in the car yeah like i'm
just donald's drive-through maybe we
could do our
mcplant video yeah love it okay that's a
good idea
right that's really what i wanted to do
just like i love spending my weekends in
the car
when will your vlog of pub day be up do
you think well you think you can get to
it today
it's done your current condition not
only did i literally
like take over the world yesterday i
also put the vlog together
on like my two hour break yeah um
at like five o'clock and it's pretty
much done it's like add some music and
some you know captions and
things but it's done hopefully we can
see it today or tomorrow
yeah i can get it out today patreon.com
morning toast
there's some good content on there right
now yeah no it's premium and the rest of
the month because it's all there
everything we've ever done and the rest
of the month we've got like good [ __ ]
planned
and next month like we're already queued
up i'm gonna do my house tour for next
month i'm really excited
okay cool keep pushing it off no i mean
well because i did my other vlog this
month it was like i'm just not gonna do
two of me in a month
i just don't want anyone to like be sick
of me we could never be sick of you
thanks me on the other hand um
okay we're gonna put this to bed we're
gonna put this to bed you gotta take a
nap you gotta prepare for the redheads
episode will be out
tomorrow and not so exciting thank you
so much for listening to the
wait you know what before i wrap up i
just really want to thank everyone who
bought my book like i know i've been
[ __ ] around today because i'm like
not feeling well
but yesterday like it's a blur like
first of all
was not there but just thank you so much
everyone who like got the book posted on
instagram like was so excited chasing
down their amazon delivery man like
i love that so much and i really just
i'm very very grateful so i wanted to
put that out there
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fastback
stories that you need to know every
monday friday and youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i already
cast walks all the places baby listen to
podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are also if you already read my
book
feel free to review it you know yes
before the former toasters get there
i prefer goodreads as that's where i go
to seek out reviews and where i review
all the books so
goodbye then amazon works oh nice and
please um
only go review it if you're gonna leave
it five stars if not don't bother
yeah four is good too sure five yeah
five is better
love you bye bye
you